William Martinet bonsoir bonsoir député
lui pèse de la onzième circonscription
des Yvelines vous est déposé pour votre
groupe à l'Assemblée nationale une
proposition de loi visant à prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour protéger les
locataires de la hausse des loyers et
des charges on rappelle juste le
contexte la fin de la trêve hivernale
est intervenue le 31 mars dernier avec
des Français on le rappelle toucher par
un contexte économique contraint cette
crise énergétique notamment l'inflation
pourquoi avoir déposé cette proposition
de loi à vos yeux aujourd'hui le
gouvernement ne va pas assez loin avec
la mise en place de son bouclier
tarifaire et le gel de l'indice de
référence des loyers jusqu'en juin
le problème aujourd'hui c'est que le
renchérissement du prix du logement est
une véritable bombe sociale et
l'objectif de ma proposition de loi
c'est d'apporter des solutions pour
réussir à la désamorcer puisque le
problème du coût du logement c'est un
problème ancien il s'agit pas dire que
il date seulement dit à quelques mois
mais dernièrement il y a eu plusieurs
décisions du gouvernement plusieurs
éléments de contexte qui ont fait que
subitement le prix du logement s'est
renchéri donc il y a une décision du
gouvernement qui est particulièrement
regrettable c'est celui en juillet
dernier d'avoir décidé de d'augmenter
l'IRL l'indice de référence des loyers
de 3,5%. donc cela permet en cours de
bail qu'un bailleur décide d'augmenter
de 3,5% les loyers c'est un chiffre
historique unilatérale exactement c'est
ça c'est vraiment parle de locataire qui
ont déjà signé un bail et qui reçoivent
un courrier de leur bailleur disant ça
va être à partir de maintenant 3,5% plus
cher donc ça c'est un premier problème
et deuxième problème que nous avons et
qui concerne beaucoup d'habitants de ma
circonscription c'est celui du
renchérissement du prix des charges
parce que vous savez que il y a
actuellement une crise sur le marché de
l'énergie qui fait que l'électricité le
gaz coûte beaucoup plus cher et les
bailleurs sociaux mais aussi les
copropriétés n'ont pas accès aux tarif
réglementé de l'énergie donc quand les
prix sur le marché explosent ils doivent
répercuter ça sur les charges qui sont
facturées au locataire et moi j'ai pu
constater si je ne parle que des
bailleurs sociaux de locataires de
séquences de résidence Yvelines Essonne
de Valophis donc là on parle de
plusieurs villes de la circonscription à
qui le bailleur a annoncé plus 50 + 100
+ 150 euros de charges tous les mois je
parle pas d'une régularisation de
Charles je parle d'un prix qui augmente
tous les mois et ça ça met des familles
dans une détresse sociale vraiment
vraiment terrible donc l'idée de la
proposition de loi c'est d'intervenir
sur ces deux principaux sujets de dire
on revient sur l'augmentation de l'IRL
qui a été décidée par le gouvernement
parce que c'était une mauvaise mesure et
deuxième proposition c'est de dire on
bloque les prix de l'énergie y compris
pour les bailleurs et les copropriétés
pour éviter cette explosion des charges
et vous allez expliquer aussi cette
proposition de loi ce 14 avril à
Fontenay-le-Fleury a des associations de
locataires on va voir ce qu'ils pensent
d'une telle proposition de loi on est
tout à fait d'accord avec les
propositions qui sont faites compte
tenues que nous on est vraiment sur le
terrain et on peut vous confirmer que
c'est une nécessité il y a des appels
énormes sur les locataires
et ça passe très mal ça passe très très
mal parce que c'est le pouvoir achat les
locataires qui touchait là parce que
nous la série on avait déjà demandé
c'est que la part des charges
au niveau de la location logement soit
plus importante parce que la location
logement actuellement
à 95% quoi c'est sur le loyer mais le
loyer bouge moins finalement que les
charges
quand vous je sais pas si vous avez vu
mais sur certaines résidences les gens
du sens 150 euros d'augmentation par
mois de charges
vous le disiez vous avez eu écho de
quelques situations alarmantes et
notamment pour des locataires qui
habitent la onzième circonscription des
Yvelines c'est peut-être aussi ce qui a
nourri votre réflexion sur ce projet de
loi tout à fait même je peux aller plus
loin j'ai fait cette proposition de loi
de par les retours que j'ai eu des
habitants de la circonscription même
pour tout vous dire ça a commencé au
mois de juillet dernier j'étais au
quartier du Bois de l'étang à la
verrière et là il y a des locataires qui
sont venus me voir et qui m'ont dit
Monsieur le Député j'ai mes charges
locatives qui augmentent de 150 euros
par mois il y a même pour tout vous dire
quand les locataires m'ont dit ça la
première réponse que je leur ai faite
c'est peut-être que vous vous êtes
trompé 150 euros par mois vous confondez
avec une régularisation de charge et du
coup c'est locataire m'ont emmené le
courrier de leur bailleur donc en
l'occurrence c'est séquences le bailleur
qui a envoyé ce courrier et c'était bien
des augmentations de 150 euros par mois
donc j'ai pu mesurer cette détresse là
parce que derrière vous savez c'est des
familles surtout dans le logement social
qui ont des petits salaires ou des
petites retraites voilà à qui il y avait
peut-être 300 200 euros de reste à vivre
et si vous enlevez la moitié de tout ça
avec une augmentation de charges vous
mettez des gens dans une situation de
détresse terrible est-ce que cette
proposition là on peut l'avoir aussi
comme une réponse à la loi qui a été
adoptée très récemment en deuxième
lecture l'Assemblée nationale déposée
par le député Renaissance Guillaume
kasbien qui entend lutter contre les
occupations illicites des logements et
notamment des locataires qui font face à
des situations d'impayés oui parce que
cette loi casse Barrio dont vous parlez
sa première conséquence concrète c'est
de faciliter d'accélérer les expulsions
locatives donc si on refait un peu le
fil de toutes les décisions qui ont été
prises par le gouvernement depuis un an
qu'est-ce qu'on a augmentation de l'IRL
donc des loyers les charges locatives
que le gouvernement laisse filer sans
agir et une loi qui facilite les
expulsions pour les familles qui sont en
situation d'impayés excusez-moi mais
quand on fait le bilan de tout ça on a
le sentiment que le gouvernement est en
train de tendre un piège au locataire il
rend le logement plus cher et pour ceux
qui n'arriveraient pas à payer il
facilitent les expulsions donc
effectivement ma proposition de loi
c'est la logique totalement inverse ce
qu'il a priorité pour moi c'est le au
logement et de protéger les familles
celles qui ont des difficultés
financières mais aussi les autres parce
que plus 3,5% de loyer et des dizaines
d'euros en plus pour les charges ça
frappe tout le monde même les classes
moyennes et c'est toujours un problème
alors vous avez commencé en parler
qu'est-ce que vous proposez concrètement
peut-être de baisser l'IRL c'est à dire
mais c'est peut-être les loyers comment
faire entendre à des bailleurs qu'il
faut baisser les loyers aujourd'hui
alors effectivement il y a dans cette
proposition loi une mesure qui consiste
à baisser l'IRL pour finalement abroger
la décision qui a été prise par le
gouvernement c'est vrai que c'est un
effort qui est demandé aux propriétaires
bailleurs mais la question elle est très
simple on est dans une période de crise
c'est difficile pour pour tout le monde
il y a un problème de pouvoir d'achat
les prix qui qui explosent donc la
question c'est à qui doit-on demander
des efforts dans cette période et ce
qu'on le demande au locataire qui sont
principalement des salariés généralement
modestes ou de classe moyenne qui sont
aussi beaucoup des jeunes des étudiants
est-ce que ça veut qu'on demande
l'effort ou est-ce que c'est au
propriétaire bailleurs moi je pense que
c'est plus raisonnable de le demander
aux propriétaires d'ailleurs encore une
fois l'effort qu'on demande c'est juste
de dire n'augmentez pas le loyer c'est
quelque chose de tout à fait raisonnable
on en est actuellement dans le parcours
législatif la loi est déposée doit être
encore validée c'est ça aujourd'hui oui
alors j'ai déposé cette loi il faut que
l'administration de l'Assemblée
nationale valide qu'elle soit bien bien
conforme ce qui je pense ne posera pas
de question par contre après le vrai
sujet c'est est-ce que cette proposition
loi sera mise à l'ordre du jour de
l'Assemblée nationale et ça ça dépend de
ce qu'on appelle la Conférence des
présidents à l'Assemblée nationale avec
une majorité de députés qui sont du côté
des macronistes donc pour l'instant je
me fais pas d'illusion sur le fait que
c'est pas demain que cette proposition
de loi soit à l'ordre du jour et en même
temps et en même temps je me dis que
cette question de l'augmentation des
loyers et des charges elle concerne tout
toute la population et du coup tous les
députés sont concernés quel que soit
leur bord politique parce que je sais
que même chez mes collègues macronistes
où LR ou modem ou je ne sais qui dans
leur circonscription ils ont des
locataires qui les sollicitent sur cette
sur cette situation donc j'espère que
j'arriverai à convaincre tout le monde
et que peut-être dans un élan
transpartisan face à l'urgence social
cette loi elle puisse être étudiée
adoptée une question très importante
vous le dites vous pensez que on peut
débattre dans un climat serein on sait
que le climat était tendu très
dernièrement avec cette réforme des
retraites mais pourquoi est-ce que le
climat est tendu à cause de la détresse
sociale des gens voilà tout simplement
pourquoi est-ce que les gens s'opposent
avec vigueur à la réforme des retraites
parce que travailler deux ans de plus
c'est quelque chose qui leur paraît qui
leur paraît très compliqué et donc là
c'est la même chose sur la question la
question du pouvoir d'achat il va bien
falloir un jour prendre à bras le corps
cette question du pouvoir d'achat
qu'est-ce qu'on voit maintenant c'est
que même dans les supermarchés on a des
antivols qui sont mis sur la viande
enfin je veux dire on est arrivé dans
quelque chose où l'inflation elle met
les gens dans une situation de grande
détresse donc il faut agir et quel est
un des principaux postes de dépenses des
français surtout ceux de région
parisienne parce qu'on a assez là qu'on
a le logement le plus cher bon bah c'est
payé son son loyer donc on résoudra pas
le problème du pouvoir d'achat et de
l'inflation si on s'attaque pas à ce
sujet des loyers qui sont trop chers
c'est ce que propose ma proposition de
loi merci William Martinet député de la
11e circonscription des Yvelines je le
rappelle vous venez de déposer donc une
proposition de loi visant à prendre des
mesures d'urgence pour protéger les
locataires de la hausse des loyers et
des charges